aujourd'hui pour avoir votre candidature
aux élections législatives où est
notamment soutenue par la france
insoumise
[Musique]
c'est quoi être un insoumis ont fait
finalement
en tout cas j'ai par contre attendu
d'être soutenue par la france a joué je
lui aussi par le parti communiste par
ensemble parents voient plus que le
gilet vert pour être a soumis quand tu
fais des mouvements plus c'est que tu
vas tu vas le voir rentrer dans quelque
chose que tu vas voir les obstacles faut
vivre avec des obstacles et par exemple
dans les luttes de jean luc mélenchon sa
personnalité vous voulez des
convergences une c'est un exemple c'est
le foot
après il ya beaucoup de reproches à
faire à jean luc mélenchon sans doute
m'envahit bien qu'elle par exemple en
obligeant certains médias il y a du
tempérament
via c'est pas évident de pouvoir ce
qu'on peut se prendre dans la figure
même quand tu fais des petites luttes
locales et quand tu es candidat au
niveau local tu te prends quand même des
trucs bon faut être costaud
bon bah il y a du tempérament et yanzhou
coal sommes donc voilà ekissi peut faire
mieux justement qu'est-ce qui selon vous
dans quel domaine il va pas assez loin
par exemple prononcer non appel comme
dirait ma mère ma mère elle m'a dit que
je parle trop bêta depuis que je suis
passé mais il faut qu'il arrive à un
faux et qu'il arrive à sourire encore
plus quoi il faut qu'il arrive à être
sympa il faut que nos mères elle le
trouve sympa quoi